hello may I speak with Paul Romer please
this is Adam Smith calling from
nobelprize.org the website of the Nobel
Prize in Stockholm okay well first of
all many many congratulations on the
award of the Prize in Economic Sciences
thank you
you sound nicely calm I think it takes a
while for a pissed-off
thinking no I can imagine I won't ask
whether it's a surprise because of
course a couple of years ago and why you
released a press release saying you'd
have been awarded the prize by the state
I just mention that yeah but
unfortunately this is something that
universities tend to prepare for and
I've sort of been through this trial
including this this release it's
actually not the first time that
happened there was an email that went
out when I was at Stanford but um anyway
I've got some experience with with this
um nobody I think nobody prepared a
press release that I mean you notice at
this time and I was sound asleep so it
caught me off guard well never mind they
can dig out the other ones here though
um you've been awarded the prize for
analyzing the relationship between
innovation and the economy and we all
know that innovation drives growth in
GDP but what do you think is the most
important thing that you'll work teaches
us what happens with technology is under
our control if we collectively set our
minds to improving technology as a
particular type we can do that and it
takes some collective actions and
supports the research or some provision
of patent protection or a mixture of the
two and some focused energy it takes
even policies like commitment to open up
systems as University education that
everyone
but if we set our minds to improving the
technology we can improve it in the
direction that seems important to us and
even at a faster rate so instead of
treating it as something that just
happens to us like the weather we should
treat it as something we can treat it to
something but we we control and this
fostering research and development
enough or do you need more to make it
one well one other thing I should say is
that if you look at the very long sweep
of history
what you see is that the rate of growth
has been speeding up the rate of
progress and that's because there's more
and more people who we're all engaged in
this process of discovery and then once
everyone discovers something they can
they can share it so a very important
part of supporting this kind of research
is making it possible for as many people
as possible to know what we've already
discovered to communicate what they've
discovered and to sure this process of
learning what we know and then going out
and making making new discoveries so it
isn't just a question as what any one
nation does but it's also a question of
how effectively we connect with
everybody anywhere in the world and
share all of the insights that are
discovered anywhere what I think of that
say a pharmaceutical that might now keep
my mind sharp in 20 years or 30 years I
don't care if it's discovered in the
United States or someplace else in the
world I just care that somebody
discovers it and if there are a lot more
people all over the world working on
things then it's much more likely that
we'll discover indeed and and there
seems to be a race among nations to
become the technological leaders of
course but then one also has to think
about the nations that are left behind
perhaps no notion about this possibility
of sharing
is a very optimistic result for
countries that are left behind they
don't have to reinvent the wheel they
can take advantage of what's already
known and so the challenge of
development is figuring out what are the
impediments that prevent that flow of
knowledge to those countries and what
can policymakers do to remove those
impediments and then take advantage of
this very rapid growth that countries
get when they start catching up lovely
thank you well hopefully we'll get a
chance to talk about all this and more
when you're in Stockholm in December to
receive your prize thank you so much and
once again congratulations okay thank
you thank you